today the U.S Capitol reopens to
tourists for the first time since the
pandemic began in 2020 in just three
days before the second anniversary of
the deadly January 6th attack now the
police chief who defended Congress that
day is speaking out Stevenson's new book
courage Under Fire which is out today is
his inside story of the capital Siege
and as son told Robert Costa he is
concerned about the possibility of
another attack
brutality I saw was you know just the
worst thing I've ever seen in my life as
far as attacks on police
former U.S Capitol Police Chief Steven
Sund says the officers outnumbered 58-1
were also battling for help I was making
every call I could and people were
coming they're sending the calvary and
that is what ultimately turned the tide
as rioters barreled in and breached the
Senate chamber son alleges he lost
critical minutes with bureaucratic
delays to get back up I then have to get
on a call with the military at 2 34 pm
and start begging and pleading for
National Guard assistance sun says he
asked for more National Guard support
days earlier only to be stymied by
congressionally appointed law
enforcement officials adding to the
problem he says was an alarming lack of
coordination with other government
agencies leading up to the attack I
believe January 6 was treated
differently than other major events in
Washington DC we've done Pope's visits
we've done imfs and there's certain
things that usually take place with
briefings intelligence bulletins joint
intelligence bulletins that didn't
happen this time
you know I sit back and I wonder whether
they they just missed him was there a
bias or was it watered down purposely
there's a lot of people within the
president's cabinet that was concerned
he may try and invoke the Insurrection
act and if he had enough intelligence
saying that you know Armageddon was
coming uh it would give him the the um
ammunition he needs to invoke that that
act the January 6 house select committee
said it found no evidence that the delay
in sending the National Guard was
intentional the Inspector General who
investigated the actions of Capitol
Police officials surrounding January 6
cited multiple deficiencies including
failure to disseminate intelligence and
prepare a comprehensive plan this
internal intelligence bulletin from
Sun's own department just three days
before the attack warned armed
protesters could come to Washington but
call detailed information limited as the
chief of the United States Capitol
Police
I have no problem with the buck stopping
with me I'll take my lumps wherever I
deserve them there's things I could have
and should have done better I am calling
for the resignation of the capital the
chief of the capital police Mr son
forced out the day after the attack son
says he's not sure the problem is fixed
January 2025 should the United States
be concerned I am very concerned that
this could happen again but son says
stopping that may take more than better
barriers in planning society as a whole
I think we are so divided I think
politicians on both sides need to start
thinking about how words matter and
start finding a way to heal this place
in a statement ahead of Friday's
anniversary the Capitol Police has
highlighted changes they have made since
the attack that includes hiring a new
intelligence director and legislation
that grants more authority to the
Capitol Police Chief to declare an
emergency or call in the National Guard
Adriana
important changes Bob thank you so much